how have you never hooked up with  Anderson Cooper because you guys were  set up and then that didn't happen it  didn't he said that he had a phone call  which I thought went great and he said  that he could just see me flailing  around on the phone and that I was too  enthusiastic for him  flailing m22 Kenzie Lyon I just stick  you laid and so it was too much for him  he and I are on tour right now I will  what it's called the AC to tour and what  do you guys do we interview each other  and then the audience interviews us it  is so fun it's really people are always  like I want to go hang out with you and  your friends I want to go take you out  for a drink whatever this is like  hanging out with us